I'm trying something a little bit
different for this YouTube video.
Partially because of a time constraint,
I have an appointment that's coming up
in like 15 minutes. So, I have about 10
minutes to shoot this video. So, I'm
going to do it in one take. So, it might
not be perfect, but I want to share some
thoughts I have around storytelling.
And I'm quite passionate about
storytelling because I think it's
something that helps any speech. I would
argue any great speech or presentation
needs to have some element of stories
within it. It's going to help the
audience remember the information. It's
going to keep their attention. But, even
businesses are starting to grasp the
importance of storytelling. And the
number of LinkedIn job requests or job
postings that included the term
storyteller has dramatically gone up in
the last few years because companies
recognize this ability to tell a great
story can actually translate to sales.
So, I want to give some thoughts off the
top of my head with regard to
storytelling, what's important, and
things to avoid. And what I will start
off with is the idea of jumping right
into a speech with a story. Because so
many people, they begin speeches with
formalities. "Hey everyone, for those
who don't know me, my name is Wade, and
today I'm going to talk about this and
this and this."
Many speakers do that.
The problem is audiences have heard that
before, and it's not that interesting.
It's not adding value. Or they come up
and they say, "Hey, how's everyone doing
today?"
And again, it's kind of cheesy. It
doesn't really capture the audience's
attention.
Instead, if you jump right into a story,
last summer, I was going to meet some
friends,
and then one of the scariest things
that I've ever experienced in my life
happened to me.
Okay,
now the audience is thinking, "Whoa,
what what happened? This is interesting.
I'm invested." And if those are the
first words out of your mouth when you
were giving a speech, that is very
different. You are disrupting a pattern,
you are capturing the audience's
attention right away. So, starting a
speech with a story is incredibly
powerful. One thing you want to avoid
doing when
giving stories in a speech is giving
stories that don't have any sort of
relevance to the overall point or things
that your audience can't really relate
to.
This isn't to say you can't tell
personal stories. Personal stories are
encouraged, but the problem is is that
if I just tell a story for the point of
telling a story, maybe to get some
laughs, sure, that might be entertaining
in the short term, but if there's no
real connection, it kind of
lacks energy. It It depletes the purpose
of the speech. Audiences might be a
little bit confused. Well, what does
that have to do with everything else
that you're talking about? And so, it
can distract from your overall message.
Instead, you always want to be thinking
about the audience, the why. What is it
that you hope that they're getting from
this presentation? Focus on that.
The next mistake people make from time
to time when telling stories is getting
hung up on the little details that
really don't matter that much. An
example of this, I was out for dinner a
few months ago, and there was somebody
who was telling a story, and she wasn't
100% sure on the details. So, the story
she was pretty sure happened in October,
or wait, was it September, or maybe it
was even August that the story happened.
Anyways, she was at a restaurant, and
she ordered the nachos, or or was it the
tacos, or what exa-
These details probably aren't essential
to the story, but some people have this
this need, this feeling, a very powerful
urge to have to
make sure that everything is 100%
accurate. But, the problem with that,
when you're constantly jumping in and
correcting your own story, each time you
do that, it disrupts the story a little
bit. It takes away some of the umph,
some of the emphasis from that
presentation, from that story, and it
sidetracks things. And so, if you were
listening to the story and there's all
of these constant little interruptions
on the details,
you're more likely to get distracted, to
be less interested. So, if you were
telling a story,
if the details aren't essential, it's
fine. It's fine if you got the month
wrong, or the restaurant wrong, or the
thing you ate that evening wrong,
especially if it's not essential to the
story. And a bonus tip, if you were the
type of person who likes to correct
other people, so they're in the middle
of a story and you jump in, "No, it
didn't happen this way."
Stop doing that. Stop doing that because
you are taking away from their story.
And again, if it is not an essential
part of it,
there's no point. It's just disrupting a
great story. I lied. There was one small
edit. There's one stitch in this video
because there was an important point and
I couldn't remember it off the top of my
head, which is funny because that point
has to do with memorization. You see,
many people struggle to memorize their
speech, and they have a very tough time
detaching from notes. They write
everything down word for word, and then
when they give a presentation, they want
to have those notes and give that
presentation, but when you read notes
verbatim off of a sheet of paper, it is
very distracting, the voice often goes
monotone, it eliminates the ability to
use body language, it takes away from
the impact of your speech. And so,
one of the reasons or the great benefits
to incorporating stories, not just is it
more interesting for the audience, like
audience members would rather hear a
great story, especially if it relates to
your point, than listen to a bunch of
data or statistics. Stories are more
interesting, they're more likely to be
remembered
by a crazy
amount, like like some people have said
22 times more likely to be remembered.
Stories will be more remembered than
facts alone,
but also it helps you in building your
speech. Because if you tell stories that
you have told many times before to
friends or family members or colleagues,
now you don't need to write those
stories down word for word and read them
off of a piece of paper, because they're
they're up here already. Instead you if
you really need to have notes, you could
just have a little bullet point reminder
that tells you what the story is, and
then that'll just be your cue to go and
tell a story that you are already
familiar with telling.
This video, this this one edit, almost
one take video,
is all to reinforce the idea that
storytelling is not just
a nice to have, it is essential. It is
an essential piece of any great speech.
I don't care if it is a professional
business presentation, I don't care if
it's a wedding speech, whatever the
format, a virtual call, stories help
make your speeches better, full stop.
So, make sure you're telling great
stories, and hopefully some of these
tips about storytelling help you on the
next presentation.